ora i metallica
tra l'altro io ho notato ragazzi che non
sono ho notato prima che qua c'è
qualcosa ma cos'è solo gli achievement
non so chi fossero gli achievement isto
gioco ma dai dipendenti senza madonna
quanti ce ne sono non c'è quello per
fare schifo sì perché l'ho vinto subito
crew che tutto questo è da una vita che
ancora non fuggo quindi se riusciamo è
meglio walk on to my giorno a ragazzi
abbiamo una scorta considerevole di
zuppe e di acqua che sono abbastanza
buoni ma tanto che grazie a mary jane
dura cinque minuti
allora vediamo se riusciamo a fare una
partita decente almeno oggi tentativo di
vittoria ragazzino mi stanchero mai di
spettacolo bellissimo come quando
probabilmente io a 70 anni di costruire
un bunker finirò così se continuiamo a
buttarla plastica nel mare anche domani
ok ragazzo alla sua partita minnie
secondo me di parte
sono molto fiducioso e lo sono sempre
perdo sempre però ragazzi voglio
arrivare al giorno cinque esperimento
senza dare niente a nessuno così giusto
per capire se effettivamente cinque
giorni possono sopravvivere
il padre è preoccupatissimo per cinque
giorni abbiamo appurato che possono
stare senza acqua e cibo quindi
ricordate quello che non si sa mai
acqua cibo per tutti e adesso almeno
quattro giorni
il cibo ogni 7 quindi teoricamente ci
dovremmo allora ogni anno fatto di
visita di di sì davvero bizzarri 1 le
ore invitava al rumore di un cavallo al
galoppo battendo due pietre pietro
allora ragazzi sembra che la zona sia
ancora irradiata uscire in questo
momento è pericoloso quindi una credenza
del rifugio era un po instabile così
l'abbiamo spostata per i posizionarle
così abbiamo scoperto la porta segreta
che dove conduce a teoricamente di sotto
dovrei portare il fucile ma vi cavo
addosso ogni la torcia
vediamo se riusciamo a trovare le
provviste in questa zona segreta del
rifugio cosa è trovato senza trovare
nulla malacca a quanto pare abbiamo già
un nostro personale orto a post
apocalittico abbiamo trovato degli
strani funghi che crescevano su una
delle pareti sono abbastanza grandi per
farli bene prezzi sono abbastanza grandi
per fare de france etto e se oggi
preparassimo un banchetto a base di
funghi ma certo figurativi casa l'hanno
radioattivi qualcuno ha bussato alla
porta e occhio
c'è qualche problema di fondo che che
puzza ma chi è che il monache bus al
bunker e orlando da qua qua qua con dalì
dell'acqua adesso va bene prendetevi st
acquah tutti
maledetti no è squillato il telefono
della città vicino non me ne frega
niente
tanto non serve a nulla ragazzi sta
chiamata 0 proprio dolore della
fotografia dolori sono pizzetti da sta
ancora male chiedermi nei più assetato
nessuno ha fame non mangia della città
giorni va bene non vedo niente sono mi
chiede allora acqua per tutti dolores
devi correre con la valigetta in mano e
cerca assolutamente di portare indietro
roba
io non ho capito se la valigetta serve
solo per portare più oggetti non lo so
ragazzi non ho mai capito star aveva
però io gli dò gli oggetti sempre
lascia la fisarmonica non so cosa ti
possa servire però la mappa provaci dai
ragazzi ho fatto una cacata mostruoso
dagli stessero mostruosa ma credo che
con tutta questa roba lei possa tornare
e fare veramente razzia di rob è però
non lo so perché io in genere con la
valigia io gliela do vuota per portare
il più roba capito non gliela do mai per
portare più oggetti prove
vediamo allora ne avesse dato che non
solo mandono sono mangiare ma il giorno
21 di darina fregiare va bene è tornata
la mamma portaci tutto ciò medikit va
bene cosa ma i capelli di timmy cos'è
successo a chi mi aspetta fermi tutti
che è successo ma cos'è successo a
quest'uomo ha riportato tutto quindi
ottimo tranne la fisarmonica che
distrutta quanto pare che non c'è più ma
chi se ne frega nella mensa
dell'ospedale hanno trovato matita note
all inizio poi pomodoro beh più uno
ultimamente dovere se non è molto
loquace meglio parlare e capire cos'è
che non va è stata fuori otto giorni
quindi sarà quello il messaggio trovato
oggi alla porta ci ha accolti tutti di
sorpresa ci chiedeva di portare delle
provviste in un posto prestabilito
firmato amici amici quale amici
non sappiamo chi sia questa gente ma
abbiamo la possibilità di scoprire e
hanno promesso che non ce ne pentiremo
ottimo dovremmo aiutarli ovviamente dai
una zucchina l'aria
ho rischiato a dare questa turbina però
secondo me qualcosa ci danno è successo
che c'è andato gli autori dei messaggi
sono rivelati essere legge melli
fratello e sorella ci hanno salutato
cortesemente ci hanno portati una
piccola tenda hanno promesso di racconti
di contattarci presto va più over
sono contento mica tanto vabbè dai tende
potrebbe sopravvivere non possiamo
andare dolores mari gen si sente così
così mandare timi fuori un po rischioso
dai proviamo continui io sono fiducioso
a michael io lo manderei fuori con la
mappa team i ragazzi lo mando fuori con
la mappa solo ed unicamente perché ho
paura semi schioppa con la mappa sono
morto però e devo rischiare ragazzi se
non hanno una nessuno vale riporta mela
ti prego prima la mappa poi il tuo culo
però prima abbiamo giocato a fai una
lista delle cose che ho di di più per
qualche motivo il nome del nostro vicino
continuava a spuntare ci è venuto in
mente che quel viscido aveva una
cassaforte in salotto ci siamo sempre
chiesti che cosa ci fosse dentro forse
ora il momento di scoprirlo ma chi avrà
l'onore di rubare i beni della nostra
nei mesi indolore
l'unica già malata quindi esci che tanto
dai timi ti prego torna torna perché non
ce la facciamo più
al 33 di giorno eccolo 32 va bene cosa
ha portato tutto ha portato tutto questo
bambino genio
cosa ti sei portato più una mappa a
posto mamma mia che figlio che è figlio
molonia fantastico benissimo ragazzi
secondo me dolore smi schioppa domani
prove chimici a un miliardo di cose non
è un fan delle punture ha bisogno di una
grossa iniezione prima e meglio è
ragazzi muoiono tutti perché stanno
morendo di di malattia ma io come faccio
cenno nemmeno un corso 37 daranno fame
però in tutto questo
cioè si ci hanno pane ma non così tanto
acque zuppo ragazzi per arrivare abbiamo
deciso di dare un'occhiata veloce
all'esterno per controllare se ne
conservando lo fosse ancora in piedi
siamo stava per uscire con la base di
torri indio nell'oscurità aveva pochi
attimi per decidere che cosa fare
insetticida anche se è un non è un
insetto control cane
ecco la malattia rigorose e di dolores è
degenerata ed è morta la malattia di
medicine è peggiorata quando ha scoperto
nella mia medicina ha deciso di partire
per andare in cerca di una cura ci ha
lasciato indietro dice che non tornerà
visto che questa città non è mai
piaciuta fine però se notate ragazzi la
figlia non muore mai scappa sempre
e non posso farci niente io sono no no
no no non ho medicina mele mica me lo
invento o gruppo di dottori oggi ha
bussato alla nostra porta chiedendo
delle provviste per rifornire i loro kit
medici non abbiamo dubitato atti una
loro buona fede distaccavano camicie
accessori da medici dovremmo aiutarli
non saranno mai dei medici però magari
ti danno un kit quindi io ci provo
non lo so
mica un kit non va dato niente porta ma
non siamo soli sembra che ci sia un
coniglio enorme peloso nascosto in uno
dei tubi a volte tira fuori la triste
fissare uno sguardo famelico le nostre
misere scorte di cibo
non possiamo permettere che le prenda
non possiamo permettere che sia qui
mentre noi dormiamo mai non ho niente lo
scacciarlo tieniti il coniglio mangiano
prima che lui ma gite non ho idea di un
coniglio la bestia di un rito re ha
vinto già sconfitti e rovato il nostro
cibo va bene
tieni però chi se ne frega ed è pronto
riscatto proprio idra fuori mano o ted
non è più affamato e tende non è più
assetato ma non mi dire quindi come sta
messo e sono stremato non ha niente
stremato per cosa poi scusa dormi cioè
cosa vuoi frazionamento guarda che se
mando 3 2 fuori e in ottima forma per
una spedizione solo quando fuori secondo
me lui fa i disastri vai fuori t
cerca le cose perché è veramente a posto
c'è veramente già tutto sta da dio
vai giorno 52 almeno se lo mando fuori
scorrono i giorni o finisce il gioco
scorrono i giorni
quindi vai ted valigetta e maschera
antigas
ok così non ti ammali ma i giorni
passano teoricamente non sono morto
quindi quanto se quanto sei stato fuori
è ritornato stremato ha fame stanchezza
59 è ritornato con tutto qua ragazzi
fino a fino al livello 100 rivoli 4
zuppe 66 acqua e un fucile i proiettili
ottimo ti sei meritato tutto tutto tito
ragazzi lo faccio riuscire di nuovo
perché mamma mia
siamo all 85 se io veramente ragazzi non
so cosa dire se così al centesimo
livello e lo sto facendo veramente non
saranno più cosa dire e aveva trovato un
libro i boy scout ottimo by certo
resterebbero tutto tranne la masca
antigas cioè tutto non ti ammalare ti
prego
al 90 ci arrivi teoricamente 90 91 93 no
che è successo uno è morto e ted no che
è successo ragazzi cos'è sta roba
dal momento che non riuscivamo entrare
nel rifugio abbiamo bussato lato è
cercato di aprire la volta di tutti i
modi purtroppo non è servito a niente
le cose sono due o si tratta di uno
scherzo di cattivo gusto oppure chiunque
sia finito dentro e ti spaventa torino e
che dire sopra via l'apocalisse non è
mica un compito facile ma ci hanno
chiusi fuori ma non solo è morto così
votato non sembra anche ted duello
sopravvivi da un'altra parte ma dai
quindi noi siamo usciti e qualcuno era
entrato nel nostro rifugio ragazzi spero
vi sia piaciuto a me han possibile nel
finale classe tra ragazzi seguito mi
piace lasciate un commento mi piace io
voglio morire adesso sono morto morti
stupidissima dopo ore che ho giocato ma
iniziò nel 93 ma quando ci arrivò mai
più discrete a chiamare schiacciate la
campanellina prima e ragionati sui noi
video ne escono e noi come sempre ci
vediamo a rompersi o video da ragazzi
[Musica]